en este vídeo quiero hacer algunos
problemas que tienen que ver con la
pendiente de una recta también se
conocen como problemas de modelos de
variación directa y la idea es que
leamos el problema hagamos una gráfica y
después respondamos las preguntas que
nos hacen déjame empezar con este
problema dice las regaderas ahorradoras
de agua tienen un flujo de 2.5 galones
por minuto entonces lo voy a poner por
aquí
2.5 galones galones por minuto
calcula cuánto tiempo llevará llenar una
tina de baño de 30 galones utilizando
una de estas regaderas muy bien entonces
sería fantástico poder expresar la
cantidad de galones que se ha llenado la
tina en función de la cantidad de
minutos que dejamos correr el agua pero
justo esto está dado por este flujo de
acá es decir la cantidad de galones es
igual a 2.5 galones por minuto
galones por minuto multiplicado por la
cantidad de minutos que dejamos correr
el agua
y listo este de aquí es nuestro modelo
lineal o nuestro modelo de variación
directa que es un hombre es súper
sofisticado pero que básicamente nos
dice que la cantidad de galones varía
proporcionalmente con respecto a los
minutos con un factor de 2.5 muy bien
entonces ya que tenemos esto de aquí
vamos a graficar esta igualdad o bien
esta esta relación cómo le hacemos pues
nos damos cuenta que esto de aquí es en
realidad una recta las rectas son del
estilo y igual a mx más b mx más veces
cierto aquí tenemos una cosa de ese
estilo sólo que las letras están un poco
cambiadas la vez cero porque no estamos
sumando nada la aie es la g la equis es
la m porque es la variable independiente
y la m que es la pendiente es 2.5
galones por minuto muy bien entonces con
esto en mente déjame hacer la gráfica
aquí pero antes déjame cambiar esta g
esta g
a cinco medios de galones por minuto
galones por minuto
por m 5 medios y 2.5 es exactamente lo
mismo pero esto nos va a ayudar para
saber cuánto nos movemos en x y cuánto
nos movemos en ya bueno entonces ahora
sí voy a graficar con este color verde y
aquí y entonces aquí voy a poner el eje
de la variable independiente que es la
cantidad de minutos y acá el eje de la
cantidad de galones aquí va a ser la
cantidad de galones y lo que nos dice
esta pendiente es que si avanzamos 12 x
entonces avanzamos 5 en ya bueno vamos a
empezar aquí en el cero si tenemos cero
minutos entonces se han llenado cero
galones por lo tanto este punto el
origen está en la ecuación de la recta
que nos interesa ahora si avanzamos dos
unidades en x dos unidades hacia la
derecha tenemos que avanzar cinco
unidades hacia arriba 1 2 3 4 5 de modo
que este punto también está en la línea
que nos interesa vamos a hacerlo una vez
más avanzamos 2 a la derecha 1 2 3 4 5
hacia arriba y podríamos hacer lo mismo
hacia la izquierda
avanzamos 2 hacia la izquierda
pero ahora tenemos que avanzar 5 hacia
abajo 1 2 3 4 5 nos quedaría ese punto y
de modo similar avanzando 2 para acá y 5
para acá nos quedaría este punto de acá
entonces ahí tenemos 5 puntos de la
línea déjame unirlos sería de este punto
a este punto de acá
bueno creo que quedó derechito y aquí
aquí tenemos la gráfica de esta relación
que tenemos por acá ahora en realidad
nada más nos interesa lo que está en el
primer cuadrante cuando los minutos son
positivos porque no nos gusta pensar en
minutos negativos o al menos no por el
momento vale bueno entonces tenemos que
la región que nos interesa es esta de
este lado esta de acá vale bueno ahora
sí vamos a responder la pregunta a ver
si la gráfica nos sirve para algo dice
que calcula cuánto tiempo llevará llenar
una tina de baño de 30 galones entonces
tendríamos que tener la gráfica hasta el
30 pero aquí sólo la tenemos hasta 10
galones entonces para no volver a
hacerla mejor vamos a resolver este
problema algebraica mente cómo le
hacemos pues aquí tenemos la ecuación
que nos relaciona galones con minutos y
sabemos que la tina de baños de 30
galones entonces voy a poner kg vale 30
galones y voy a poner todas las unidades
para que veas que todo cuadra al final
entonces 30 galones va a ser igual
a 5 medios de galones por minuto galones
por minuto
multiplicado por la cantidad de minutos
entonces qué tenemos que hacer ahora
simplemente tenemos que dividir entre 5
galones en entre dos minutos bueno entre
cinco medios de galones por minuto de
ambos lados para despejar m vale
entonces de este lado voy a dividir
entre cinco medios de galones
por minuto y de este lado también entre
5 medios de galones por minuto
talones por minuto y justo estoy
haciendo esto para que se cancele esto
de acá para que la m quede despejada y
vamos a ver que nos queda
no voy a poner de este lado entonces m
la cantidad de minutos que dejamos que
necesitamos dejar correr el agua es
igual a 30 galones y aquí estamos
dividiendo entre 5 medios de galones por
minuto pero eso es lo mismo que
multiplicar por dos quintos de minuto
por galón minuto por galón y entonces
mira para empezar las unidades y cuadra
galones se van con galones y aquí nos
van a quedar minutos minutos muy bien y
de los números nos quedan 30 entre 5 y 6
30 entre 5 6 y 6 por 2 es 12 entonces
serían 12 minutos y por lo tanto esta de
aquí es la respuesta
tenemos que dejar correr el agua correr
el agua 12 minutos para que se llene la
tina de baja muy bien déjame pasar abajo
para resolver otro problema también es
de llenado de cosas
con agua y dice lo siguiente dice wendy
usa una manguera para llenar su nueva
alberca por primera vez ella comienza a
las 10 pm y la deja toda la noche voy
pasando esta información
voy a ponerle aquí ahora
entonces comienza a las 10 pm 10 pm y
queremos ver cuánto se llena la alberca
entonces le voy a poner aquí alberca la
cantidad de albercas llenadas es 0 vamos
a ver qué otra información tenemos a las
6 p a las 6 am o sea se fue a dormir al
día siguiente a las 6 am mide la
profundidad y calcula que la alberca
está 4 séptimos llenas ok entonces aquí
a las 6 a las 6 am m la alberca está a 4
séptimo 74 séptimo siena y nos preguntan
a qué hora se va a llenar su nueva
alberca muy bien la idea es que otra vez
vamos a plantear un modelo de variación
directa un hombre sofisticado pero es
algo muy sencillo simplemente vamos a
decir que la cantidad de albercas que se
llenan depende de una constante
multiplicada por el tiempo que ha
transcurrido vale por el tiempo que ha
transcurrido entonces sería muy bueno
poder determinar esta constante porque a
partir de ahí vamos a poder responder
las preguntas cómo le hacemos para
determina
esta constante pues déjame poner aquí
una tercera columna que es el tiempo voy
a ponerle t y vamos a pensar que a las
10pm no ha pasado nada de tiempo pero a
las 6 am si pensamos todo en horas aquí
le voy a poner que el tiempo está en
horas a las 6 am y ya pasaron 8 horas 8
horas entonces aquí en la tabla ya
tenemos información suficiente para
determinar esta constante de la
variación directa suena muy complicado
pero es muy fácil simplemente vamos a
copiar la información acá entonces cómo
le hacemos pues tenemos la información
de que la al ver que está a 4 séptimos
llena le voy a poner así 4 séptimos de
alberca alberca
al tiempo de igual a 8 entonces acá por
88 horas
entonces aquí ya podemos despejar acá
para despejar cada dividimos a ambos
lados entre ocho horas y ocho horas aquí
para que se cancele y aquí para ver que
quedan ocho horas y vamos a ver que
queda aquí esto se cancela y por lo
tanto cada la constante de variación
directa es igual a 4 entre 8 es un medio
y aquí hay un 7 en el denominador
entonces nos queda un catorceavo de
alberca alberca por ahora por ahora muy
bien estas unidades están medio raras
verdad alberca por ahora pero bueno esto
está padre porque entonces ya podemos
poner a a
como un catorceavo catorceavo
de alberca por hora cerca por hora por
la cantidad de tiempo que transcurre y
todo esto es en horas pero lo que
nosotros queremos es saber a qué horas
se va a llenar su nueva alberca es decir
queremos saber cuándo a es igual a 1
cuando tenemos una alberca llena
entonces vamos a ver cómo le haríamos
simplemente tenemos que ponerle aquí que
a es igual a 1 entonces uno sería igual
a un catorceavo un catorceavo de
albercas por ahora multiplicado por el
tiempo bueno aquí uno es una alberca
verdad aquí debería ponerle a entonces
déjame déjame ponerlo más bonito
entonces una alberca es igual a un
catorceavo de albercas por ahora
multiplicado por el tiempo y entonces
aquí podemos despejar el tiempo
multiplicando por 14 entonces nos
quedaría que el tiempo es igual a 14
horas puedes checar que las unidades en
efecto cuadran muy bien entonces esto es
aquí es el tiempo después de las 10 pm
que necesitamos para llenar la alberca
pero eso todavía no nos dice a qué hora
se va a llenar entonces hay que ser
cuidadosos de acordarnos pasar a la hora
entonces cómo le hacemos pues una forma
de pensarlo en la siguiente si empezamos
a las 10 pm entonces a las 10 am van a
haber pasado 12 horas a mí me gusta
pensarlo así y entonces si necesitamos
que pasen 14 nos faltan otras 2 y por lo
tanto dentro de otras dos horas será el
mediodía
mediodía entonces la alberca de wendy va
a estar lista al mediodía del día
siguiente muy bien ya nada más para
terminar como aquí tenemos espacio para
hacer una gráfica déjame hacer la
gráfica de esta relación vale entonces
acá voy a poner el eje a cpg
aquí va a ser el eje de la variable
independiente va a ser t y aquí va a ser
la cantidad de albercas llenadas
albercas llenas pues íbamos a poner
algunos puntos cuando t es igual a 0 la
cantidad de albercas es 0 entonces
tenemos este punto acá y para que quepa
en la gráfica o sea tenemos que avanzar
14 unidades así que déjame marcar que
éste mide 2 y 4 o sea cada marquita es
de 2
68 entonces sería 10 12 14 y vamos a
poner que esté en la escala vertical si
es de 1 en 123 y de esta forma
tendríamos este punto
avanzamos 14 subimos 1 también
tendríamos este punto de acá y por lo
tanto la gráfica se vería algo así
también sería una recta muy muy
inclinada
ok entonces con esto ya terminamos de
resolver estos dos problemas de modelos
de variación directa suena como algo
complicado pero simplemente tiene que
ver con rectas y con sus pendientes y
con encontrar la constante de
proporcionalidad espero que esta gráfica
no haya resultado muy incómoda pero
bueno espero que te haya servido todo
esto que te platiqué nos vemos en los
siguientes vídeos